die villa gelände am rande roms von hier
aus zieht silvio berlusconi dieser tage
die strippen cavaliere scheint es
tatsächlich ernst zu meinen umgarnt
einzelne abgeordnete macht geschenke
mission eichhörnchen nennen sie das
einsammeln der stimmen in bislang hat
der 85-jährige nicht genug zusammen um
sein ziel tatsächlich zu erreichen
staatspräsident italiens zu werden im
salon von marco fahrer ist berlusconi
das gesprächsthema nummer eins sein
geschäft liegt im historischen
stadtzentrum von rom und hat harte
zeiten erlebt corona lockdown
umsatzeinbruch wenn den kundinnen das
geld im portemonnaie fehlt spürt er das
sofort
was hältst du von einem zukünftigen
präsidenten unterlüß coni
bist du dafür
ja er ist ein mensch mit großer
erfahrung und ich glaube dass er dieses
amt immer im sinn hat
ein kindheitstraum in all den zeiten ist
marco fahrer anhänger von berlusconi
geblieben in seinem schaufenster
präsentiert er stolz ein foto mit ihm
berlusconi hat ihm sogar zur hochzeit
ein glückwunsch telegramm geschickt
ich war sehr beeindruckt von seinem
lächeln und seinem händedruck das ist
keine selbstverständlichkeit aber er hat
einen sehr guten kräftigen händedruck
und dann seine freundlichkeit denn er
hat diesen großzügigen charakter
doch bei aller liebe eine kandidatur von
berlusconi das tier selbst ihm zu weit
italien brauche doch ein international
respektiertes staatsoberhaupt ich sehe
er eine figur die diesen staat anders
repräsentiert also anders als silvio
berlusconi ich würde eine person
bevorzugen wie mozzarella oder draghi
weil sie unser land das nach der
pandemie in schwierigkeiten steckt
führen muss
silvio berlusconi schillernder
parteivorsitzende der forza italia
viermaliger regierungschef mehrfach
verurteilt wegen steuerhinterziehung der
sich immer noch vor gericht wegen
bestechung verantworten muss viele
verbinden mit dem medienunternehmer
multimillionär auch seine bunga bunga
partys mit jungen frauen trotz
zahlreicher skandale und skurrile
auftritte auf internationaler bühne
unterstützen parteifreunde öffentlich
die kandidatur
berlusconi hält seine kandidatur für den
quirinal für die krönung seiner langen
politischen karriere und zwar nicht nur
politisch sondern auch als mann des
sports und des fernsehens
aber berlusconi hat dieses land 30 jahre
lang gespalten und auch europa gespalten
also hat er nicht die richtigen
eigenschaften um der präsident der
republik zu sein
in den vergangenen sieben jahren hat
sérgio materieller das amt des
staatspräsidenten höchst würde voll
ausgefüllt alle überredungsversuche er
möge doch wenigstens bis zur nächsten
parlamentswahl in einem jahr
weitermachen hat der 80 jährige bislang
abgelehnt
bei seiner wahl 2015 war laura boldrini
parlamentspräsidentin
gerade materielle habe ihrer meinung
nach durch seine unabhängige
staatsmännische amtsführung gezeigt
warum dagegen gallus coni auf keinen
fall geeignet sein
weil es cooney ist ein mann der als er
an der macht war zuerst an seine eigenen
unternehmen und deren interessen dachte
und gesetze für sie machte anstatt sich
um das land zu kümmern
berlusconi ist ein sex ist und das ist
auf der ganzen welt bekannt aus all
diesen gründen ist berlusconi nicht
geeignet präsident der republik zu sein
davon unbeeindruckt haben die
parteiführer der konservativen forza
italia der rechten lega und der
rechtsradikalen fratelli d'italia
berlusconi als person bezeichnet die das
land verdienen
unterstützung kam sogar vom
fraktionsvorsitzenden der europäischen
volkspartei manfred weber
doch es gibt auch bereits
absetzbewegungen im konservativen lager
lega-chef matteo salvini stellt nun ein
ultimatum bekommen berlusconi die
nötigen stimmen bis zum sonntag nicht
zusammen müsse eine alternative
präsentiert werden
jeder friseur in rom weiß dass bisher
nicht selten die erstgenannten am ende
einen überraschungskandidaten gewichen
sind fast nächste kundin findet eine
frau sei doch eine schöne überraschung
für die italienische macho gesellschaft
es würde mir gefallen wenn zum ersten
mal wie in anderen europäischen ländern
bereits geschehen eine frau kandidieren
würde mir fallen da einige frauen ein
die aber wieder mal nicht im vordergrund
stehen
aussichtsreichster kandidat ist italiens
amtierender premierminister mario draghi
der sich seit amtsantritt weit über
italien hinaus ansehen erworben hat vor
der spitzen feder von karikaturist faro
ist in italien an sich kein politiker
sicher doch auch er findet mario draghi
mache vieles richtig und wenig falsch
hier in italien haben wir einen
heilsbringer der uns wie mir scheint vor
allem retten wird wo ihr elend oder
arbeitslosigkeit vor der pandemie wir
wollen ihnen deswegen überall einsetzen
sollte die wahl auf draghi fallen droht
berlusconi bereits mit rückzug seiner
partei aus der regierung sollte wiederum
draghi nicht zum zuge kommen drohen neue
schwierigkeiten
wenn draghi in einem klima der
zerrissenheit premierminister bleiben
würde würde die regierung meiner meinung
nach zurücktreten die regierung wird es
stürzen und an diesem punkt würde ein
sehr gefährlicher moment beginnt in
italien und damit europa nicht kennt
dieses chaos will sich auch im salon war
niemand ausmalen stabilität sei nötig
doch um das prinzip italienischer
politik zu beschreiben heißt es dazu oft
in italien es müsse sich alles ändern
damit alles so bleibt wie es ist